here's a question on many people's minds
right now where artificial intelligence
and other Advanced Technologies help or
hurt us mathematician Hannah Frye's new
show the future with Hannah fry aims to
demystify the technology that's shaping
Our Lives fry is a professor in the
mathematics of cities and she says math
can teach us a lot about ourselves even
about love in the first episode the 150
year life she discusses advances in our
understanding of DNA take a look
so now scientists they've worked out
that if you look along a strand of DNA
you can find these very particular
markers along it that can give them an
idea of how many epigenetic changes you
have experienced
which in a sense gives them a sort of
epigenetic clock on your own body and
that can tell them not only how old you
are now but also how long you're likely
to live
oh wait that is some good stuff Hannah
fry good morning how you doing very good
thank you thanks for having me so this
show is about the technology shaping our
future what would you like the viewers
to take away from this oh I think it's
that we have all have a hand in
designing it I think that a lot of the
time new technology feels like it's
something that's happening to us rather
than necessarily with us and this show
is really about opening up those
conversations in advance of the of the
technology arriving so this show covers
AI climate change the the Quest for a
longer life human emotions
um what did you learn while filming this
show oh my gosh so much so much really
yeah and I mean there's things that I
sort of half knew about and then I would
go and speak to the people who are
working on it and realize that that my
perception of it was just completely off
like nuclear fusion for example right
there's this kind of agent talk slowly
for me okay okay so age-old joke right
nuclear fusion essentially free clean
unlimited energy would completely change
the world right forever okay and there's
this joke that it's been 30 years away
forever so you know however however far
you get into the future it's still going
to be 30 years away you go and meet the
people who are working on it in this uh
in this amazing facility and France it's
like giant kind of Aging monster of this
this like International collaboration
and there are people who are standing in
front of this technology and they're so
frustrated because they're like we know
that this is the thing that will will
save the planet and no one is listening
to her and then flip over to California
where you have these fast quick startups
essentially like you know the the times
when capitalism works at its best right
and they are innovating like you would
not believe and suddenly it feels like a
much more optimistic look for the future
I was fascinated with that first episode
because a lot of people and you just
look at commercials a lot of people are
concerned about the aging process and
how to stall it how to stop it how to
preserve is there anything that you do
now as a result of doing all of those
things I don't want to give it away
to help yourself remain youthful and
feeling good uh 109 years
no so I think actually I mean again
don't want to give it away I don't think
that there is a silver bullet there's
definitely things that you can do but
when you look at the science of it it
kind of tweaks the tweaks your your
overall numbers by like a few months or
maybe a couple of years it's not very
much but what is interesting is I got to
go to Japan while I was filming this
this show and Japan has the longest life
expectancy in the world right years and
years and years longer than it is in the
United States and it's really hard to
put your finger on exactly why that is
but one thing that I really notice is
that the Japanese philosophy of finding
yeah
finding joy in little things okay and
just like seeing your life not as this
sort of challenge that has to be
completed but a series of moments to be
enjoyed so I try and do that I mean I
try I could try and do that so uh since
we're talking about the future we should
be talking about AI which you have an
episode on and you seem to be a little
more skeptical of AI than a lot of
people tell us why or actually break it
down this way should we be scared or
celebrating the arrival of artificial
intelligence
sort of both I think both things can be
true at the same time now don't get me
wrong I think that the the the the
ability for AI to completely transform
the world is is there right I think that
we have is a seismic shift and I think
that there's no going back but I also
think that we are not in a world where
any AI that's ever been created has like
a conceptual understanding of what it's
doing they it looks like they can speak
amazing you know write amazing Pros but
it doesn't really understand what it's
doing it's as good a liar as it is at
telling the truth and so I think we have
to be a bit careful about putting too
much imagining that it's that it's
better than it is because I think that
there's danger in that too all right so
you uh you did a popular Ted Talk and
you wrote a very about the mathematics
very popular about the mathematics of
Love yeah how does math coming to the
equation if you will of one of the raw's
purest forms of emotions that humans
have well so that was kind of the point
that I was trying to make right and like
slightly tongue-inch was that I was
trying to demonstrate that there is a
mathematical way of looking at anything
and even in something that is as you say
one of the rarest the subject that's
furthest away from a map as possible
yeah even then there's something you
could say because there's all sorts of
patterns right in your in your dating
life like how many people you date
before you decide to settle down which
pictures do well on internet data
algorithm in life there's yeah I mean
yeah exactly I wouldn't say I wouldn't
take my top tips as uh as as absolute
cold hard facts by the way and I was
like my own dating life is uh real quick
go on
careful now really quickly what are the
best tips for children for people who
struggle with math because you say math
isn't everything how do we make it
palatable and easy so people aren't
intimidated for all the 10 year olds who
are not you who apparently enjoyed that
yeah so I think that it is about the
enjoyment though I really think that's
it so I have two daughters and for me
it's about making it feel like a
playground not like you are being forced
into something it makes sense Hannaford
thank you so much we appreciate you cool
stuff we could talk to you all day long
all right you can watch the future with
Hannah fry starting Wednesday on the
Bloomberg app